I certainly don't believe that aids is a
punishment for homosexuality hi I sinned
can sin can definitely cause sickness I
mean if I eat too many hamburgers and I
have a heart attack well I'm not blaming
God for that
I mean it was my own choice there's no
doubt about it lifestyle choices that
all of us can give a stress back aches
headaches
and-and-and venereal diseases STDs all
kinds of things like that
lots of things lifestyle choices cost
because things
the problem with aids is the church did
not see it soon enough and we had to
repent of this my wife has talked about
this openly and so have I I did not
understand how big the issue was I just
thought oh yeah that's that's a disease
out there but isn't that just with with
gays you know you know people who have a
homosexual lifestyle and my thought on
that was that's a small percentage of
population why why I need to be working
on malaria 500 million people have
malaria okay every year why if I'm gonna
work on some let me work on something
that has a big you know 500 million
people on the other hand
it didn't matter whether it was just a
gay only gays had it or not that would
still they still need compassion and our
view is if you're driving down the
street and somebody's dying on the side
of the road and they're bleeding to
death from an accident you walked up to
him your first question is isn't was it
your fault your question is can I help
you it doesn't matter if they're
Christian or Jewish or Muslim or
Democrat or Republican or gay or
straight you just help them they're
human being in need and and the other
thing I've gotten criticized for is
working with other people who don't
believe as I do to help people who had
AIDS and so if I find somebody who's
sick on the side of the road and I can't
get him in the car to get into the
hospital I'm not gonna ask if somebody
comes over and off to help are you
Muslim are you Jewish are you gay are
you Christian are you anything I was
like can you help me and it felt partner
with me to help get that guy to the
hospital that's a good thing and so we
must always show compassion to people
with with illness Jesus
cared for the sick in fact he hung out
with the people who had AIDS of his days
called leprosy the the the AIDS of the
first century was was leprosy people who
are afraid of AIDS because I'm afraid of
leprosy they didn't know how to get it
they didn't know how you could get it
and that's the way it was in the early
80s remember I grew up in San Francisco
in the early days it was before AIDS but
the the the people didn't know how you
could get it so they were scared there's
all kinds of superstitions and and I
call a IDs
it was avoidance intolerance I can't
remember what is and then s was
suspicion or superstition